the road not taken' by Robert Frost two
roads diverged in a yellow wood and
[Music]
sorry I could not travel both and be one
traveler long I stood and looked down
one as far as I could to where it bent
in the undergrowth then took the other
as just as fair and having perhaps the
better claim because it was grassy and
wanted wear though as for that the
passing there had worn them really about
the same
[Music]
and both that morning equally lay in
leaves no step had trodden black oh I
kept the first for another day yet
knowing how way leads on to way I
doubted if I should ever come back
I shall be telling this with a sigh
somewhere ages and ages hence two roads
diverged in a wood and I I took the one
less traveled by and that has made all
the difference
[Music]
for an analysis of the poem watch this
video or check out the next poem in this
series